[Music]
on this Tuesday night another step
closer to getting home when Canadian
citizens in China could finally be flown
out why only some permanent residents
will be allowed to leave and what the
w-h-o wants done now would to stop the
outbreak he said what an MP's offensive
comments to a female colleague the
Wellness Court I would be sitting in a
jail cell right now if I hadn't
completed this program the life-changing
program putting rehabilitation /
punishment and priceless memories up for
grabs your chance to score Canadian
hockey greats collectibles
[Music]
global national with Donna freezing
tonight
Robin Gil good evening and thank you for
joining us we begin with breaking news
a fifth case of the novel coronavirus
has been identified in Canada
DC's top doctor says a woman in her 50s
has tested positive and a sample has now
been sent to the National Lab in
Winnipeg for confirmation but health
officials have not confirmed how the
woman contracted the virus she hadn't
been to China but she did have family
visiting from Wuhan the woman is an
isolation at home and said to be in good
condition this case is not unexpected it
tells us that our system is working that
we're finding people that were assessing
them safely and in the hospital setting
for example the things that we're doing
every day to prevent transmission of
influenza and the other bugs that we see
this time of year are working meanwhile
Global Affairs has told Canadians
trapped at the center of the outbreak in
China that a plane could be ready to
leave ohon as early as tomorrow there's
no guarantee that everyone who wants to
leave will be able to get out it appears
there are more people wanting out than
there are plane seats and china says
permanent residents will not be allowed
to leave unless they're needed to
accompany Canadian children that's left
some families in a state of limbo the
Canadian government says it's doing what
it can to help we have been advocating
for repatriating because obviously I saw
the news I saw this the families stories
obviously everyone wants to do their
best to bring all these people home
however I have to work with the Chinese
health authorities new video from Wuhan
today shows the chaos caused by the
outbreak hospitals are so overwhelmed
that people are lined up outside waiting
for help as of tonight more than 23,000
cases have been confirmed the number of
dead has grown to 492 most cases are in
China but at least 24 other countries
including Canada are also affected we'll
have more on the virus and what's
happening in China in just a moment but
we begin with the Canadians waiting and
hoping they'll be part of the airlift
Avigail Beeman has tonight's top story
when we can each have a child on our lap
and not be taking up any additional
seats so there's really I can't
understand any reason why it's not
doable this email from Global Affairs
Canada told Megan Millward she's
shortlisted for the Canadian flight with
her two young children but the family
was devastated to learn her husband a
permanent resident isn't on the list
reads two kids they're two so I it's
kind of hard to believe it and separate
the family Canada maintains China will
only allow Canadian citizens to leave
and a primary caregiver for a Canadian
child but not to we're gonna continue to
press I understand there's a number of
permanent residents who would like to be
repatriated as well my family is one of
the vacation they didn't go over there
to you know create a problem for anybody
and it's really just kind of escalated
into this national dilemma and I I just
want my family home permanent residents
Danielle Alou and daughter domenica are
visiting family in Wuhan but live in
British Columbia where Canadian citizen
husband and dad Monty Gisborne is
frustrated by a lack of communication
they're not on the list for the plane
I'm just trying to get my family hall
I'm getting worn down by this a little
more than 300 people have asked for
ottawa's help to get out there is a
larger number of Canadians asking for
evacuation and there is space on the
plane that's why we have already got an
option on the second plane but no word
yet on the wind that would come or who
would be allowed on board meanwhile for
many being holed up inside small spaces
for days takes an emotional toll we're
just really tired we've been trying to
campaign to get him to be allowed to go
with us and we're tired those who got
the shortlist email are told to make
their way to the airport late Wednesday
night for a Thursday morning departure
but even then there's no guarantee
they'll get on the plane due to numbers
and final approval for that flight to
take off is still in China's hands Robin
Abigail Beeman in Ottawa the government
chartered plane is now on its way to
Hanoi Vietnam once China grants final
approval the plane will fly into the
epicenter of the outbreak
Wuhan to pick up the Canadians approved
to leave after taking off from there the
plane will stop in Vancouver to refuel
all passengers will remain on board any
passenger who is sick will be taken off
the plane for treatment from Vancouver
the plane will fly to the Canadian
Forces Base in Trenton Ontario once
there all passengers will be screened
for symptoms and then kept on base under
quarantine for 14 days they'll stay at a
special military hotel at CFB Trenton
called the Yukon lodge everyone will be
placed in their own rooms with families
kept together in China authorities are
taking more aggressive steps to try to
get the outbreak under control in the
gambling city of Macau officials are now
so worried they've asked that all 41
casinos in the city be shut down for two
weeks so far ten cases have been
reported there at least one of them
involves a casino worker elsewhere in
China officials are struggling to keep
up as the virus spreads
here's Redman Shannon forget about the
numbers for a moment this is the real
human impact of coronavirus a woman
cries after being prevented from seeing
her mother's body before it is driven
away authorities are now admitting the
first patients to the newly built Wuhan
hospital and elsewhere in the city
community gyms and even convention
centers are being converted into medical
facilities for an ever-growing number of
patients the health system is struggling
to cope with some people lining up out
doors to get treatment
across the country various tactics
including drones are being used to
remind people to wear face masks in Hong
Kong a new type of protest after the
first coronavirus death in the territory
health workers demanding all border
points with mainland China be closed
leader Carrie Lam has kept three
crossings open for now I'm appealing to
those who are taking part in dissection
that lets put the interests of the
patients and the entire Public Health
System above all other things outside of
China another cruise ship is in lockdown
this time in Japan after one passenger
tested positive for the virus the World
Health Organization says this is not yet
a pandemic at least by its own
definition but it's asking the world to
start cooperating properly I'm writing
to all ministers of health to request an
immediate improvement in data sharing as
I said yesterday we can only defeat this
outbreak with global solidarity the
w-h-o again criticized blanket travel
bans against China saying they only
increase fear with little positive
effect one positive note though this 73
year old Thai patient described the
symptoms as tough but she said she's
fully recovered after hospital treatment
Redman Shannon Global News London more
than 240 WestJet passengers had their
vacations postponed because of a corona
virus hoaxes a Jamaica bound plane was
forced to return to Toronto when a 20
year old man claimed to have the virus
video taken from the flight shows the
passenger being escorted off the plane
in Toronto police say the man announced
to passengers that he had been to China
and had coronavirus in a statement
WestJet says out of an abundance of
caution our crew followed all protocols
for infectious disease on board once off
the plane paramedics determined he
wasn't sick James Polk from Vaughan
Ontario has been charged with mischief a
Conservative MP is taking heat tonight
after an exchange in the House of
Commons about sex work
Arnold Pearson's remarks were directed
at an
dpmp during a debate on the federal
parole system after a sex worker was
allegedly killed by an inmate out on day
parole here's what he said I would just
respond to that by asking the Honourable
member across the way if it's a area of
work that she is considered and if that
is an appropriate Mercedes Stevenson
joins us now Mercedes that's not a good
look for a party hoping to expand its
base what was the reaction yeah Robin
definitely not what the Tory is needed
when they've been struggling with their
brand following allegations of sexism
and misogyny in the party and as you
could imagine political opponents
pounced on this immediately the claim
that it shows what the Tories really
think of women mr. veer s'en stated that
he was trying to make a point that he
believes women are trafficked into sex
work and they simply do not choose it of
their own free will but backlash was
immediate and verson apologized
mr. speaker I'd like to apologize
unreservedly for my comments towards the
towards the members of Victoria Thank
You mr. speaker after question period
NDP leader jug meat Singh was quick to
characterize the comments as sexist I
think it was he was disrespectful to a
fellow colleague and that was wrong I
think his comments strike of misogyny
Global News asked the party of fierson
would be reprimanded but they simply
said the MPs unreservedly stands NDP MP
laurel collins the woman who was asked
the question and the female MP at the
center of this tweeted that she accepts
viren's apology but said he should
extend it to all women and not denigrate
sex work
alright Mercedes these are the kinds of
challenges the next leader will have to
deal with and we have some new numbers
on that race tonight tell us about that
yeah an exclusive poll for Global News
shows that Peter MacKay is the
front-runner in the Tory race with 40%
of Canadians saying that they would
consider voting for the Tories under
McKay's leadership that's a significant
lead but lately mckay has been his own
worst enemy he had a tone-deaf tweet
about Justin Trudeau's yoga and abrupt
end to a TV interview caught on camera
and today he backtracked on his position
on Canada's Embassy in Israel Mackay dis
cheer after the election saying that the
defeat was like having a breakaway on an
open net missing the net but with this
pace of missteps he's in danger of going
down the same road robbing Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa the trans mount
entire expansion project has cleared
another legal hurdle the Federal Court
of Appeal unanimously rejected a
challenge brought forward by four BC
First Nations groups the court found the
government conducted meaningful
consultations with indigenous peoples
and today's decision allows construction
to continue but the indigenous groups
say their fight to defend them the
environment isn't over Australia is
burning BC was burning Alberta was
burning and yet this government
government wants to double down on
building more oil pipelines that is not
a future that we can invest in the
expansion will see the existing pipeline
between Edmonton and Burnaby BC twinned
the project will increase capacity by
300,000 barrels of oil per day the
indigenous groups have 60 days to appeal
to the Supreme Court of Canada last
month the country's top court dismissed
a separate appeal from the BC government
and here's a paradox of the carbon tax
and Canadian households the
parliamentary budget watchdog says most
households will get more money back in
rebates than they'll pay through the
carbon tax the net gains are smaller
than earlier predictions after
accounting for federal and provincial
sales taxes last year
Ottawa slapped a fuel surcharge of $20
per tonne of emissions on Alberta
Saskatchewan Manitoba Ontario and New
Brunswick provinces that did not have
carbon pricing plans of their own in
April New Brunswick will implement its
own tax coming up the glitch that stole
Iowa's caucus night
Canada is a beautiful country and we
want to see your part of it
show off your Canada to Canada send your
photos to viewers at global national
calm Iowa was supposed to set the tone
for the Democratic primary season
candidates had no choice but to move on
to the next stop without knowing who won
technical issues held up results the
first batch only began trickling out a
short while ago feet booted edge is
leading the delegate counts so far with
62% of results reported followed closely
by Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren is in
third former Vice President Joe Biden
the National frontrunner for much of the
campaign is trailing in fourth place the
results debacle has raised questions
about the caucus format and whether Iowa
is still relevant in the election race
our Washington bureau chief Jackson
Prosecco is in Des Moines where he's
been watching the caucus chaos unfold
Jackson well Robin the strong
performance of a couple of candidates
suggests that Democrats are nowhere
close to being ready to coalesce behind
a single candidate not surprising at
this early juncture but the bigger
priority for the party right now is
restoring faith in the integrity of the
election after last night's debacle as
the caucuses unfolded Bernie Sanders
Pete Luda judge there was a little sign
of trouble
Iowans shuffled around gymnasiums and
living rooms to signal their support for
the Democratic candidate of their choice
especially this year you have someone
you're passionate about and some of you
think can be trunk and hopefully those
who might know in 1600 precincts like
this one in West Des Moines it went off
without a hitch until it came time to
send the final results to party
headquarters using a new smartphone app
it would not let me change that the
system crashed
leaving democrats unable to deliver
statewide results or declare a winner in
the end like there are numbers
so where are the freaking peppers months
of hype in the first in the nation state
fizzled over the course of one long
night the candidates were left
scrambling to address supporters when
those results are announced I have a
good feeling we're going to be doing
very very well the debacle killed off
candidates hopes for a rousing victory
speech it may have saved others from
embarrassment and Democrats have already
moved their campaigns to New Hampshire
the next primary state after a historic
night in Iowa which crowned at neither
winners nor losers there is no system
that is perfect and we should be
reevaluating even before last night
occurred and now for sure Jackson
president Trump delivers his State of
the Union address tonight that surely
takes away the attention from the
Democratic candidates as the Iowa
results trickle in
it really does Robin what it does is it
means that candidates like Budaj and
Sanders lost out potentially on their
breakout moment because they didn't get
to make a victory speech last night and
now while the attention is going to be
focused on Trump tonight and tomorrow it
with the impeachment inquiry meaning the
stakes in New Hampshire one week from
tonight are that much higher
Jackson Prosecco in Iowa thanks Jackson
still ahead a unique Canadian Court
appeals to boost in wellness to reduce
crime
we often report on the negative ways
Mental Health and the legal system
intersect stories about people who end
up in the system because they weren't
able to access the right help at the
right time but as Roz Lord reports there
are new unconventional methods aimed at
targeting what led to the crimes in the
first place as she entered her 20s
Makia Armstrong was headed down the
wrong path I was running the streets and
fighting people when they looked at me
the wrong way
Armstrong pleaded guilty to assault
robbery and weapons charges I would be
sitting in a jail cell right now if I
had to complete this program the program
she started after moving from the
regular court system to this one in
wellness court there's less emphasis on
punishment and more focus on recovery
the courtrooms appearance says it all
it's decorated with messages of
inspiration and artwork from
participants we look at not so much the
offense but what got people in trouble
to begin with and then try and address
those issues they pretty much showed me
do you want to go to jail and have a
criminal record and live that life since
this court started 10 years ago several
others have been established in Nova
Scotia growing momentum for a different
way of responding to mental illness and
addictions other parts of Canada have
opened similar courts they are sometimes
dismissed as a get out of jail free card
but at this meeting Wellness Court
planners rejected several applications
from people whose cases didn't meet the
criteria for mental health or addictions
programs some participants are sent back
to regular court for breaking conditions
the presiding judge Pamela Williams says
it's far from perfect but she says more
often than not it works and I think as a
society where we're beginning to see
that criminalizing mental health and
addiction issues is not it's not the
road to success compassion and empathy
or a better bet according to Tommy
Abrial who credits wellness court with
turning his life around
and treatment programs learning tools of
how to cope with mental illness the
mental illness that I have Abrial now
serves on committees that help shape
policy in the province finding new ways
for people like me Kyra Armstrong to
make a life worth living I'm hopeful for
my future
she's preparing for a post-secondary
education adjusting the scales of
justice
Ross Lord Global News Dartmouth Nova
Scotia up next a Canadian hockey legends
prized possessions go up for auction
if you rank the greatest players in the
history of hockey Jean Beliveau would
make the top ten the Montreal Canadiens
legend had size skill success and
humility
Beliveau passed away in 2014 and despite
his greatness his family has decided to
put his personal collection of awards
rings and even skates up for auction
here's Mike Armstrong imagine a 20 year
NHL career where you win the
championship
half the time Jean Beliveau hoisted the
Stanley Cup ten times on top of that
there was a scoring title to League MVPs
and the list goes on but success on the
ice didn't make the man
hockey royalty when mister Belliveau
passed away Montreal and the hockey
world mourned what was being remembered
was also who the man was
off the ice at the first Canadiens game
after his death this was how fans
thanked or honored his wife
remember TiVo has lived a life in hockey
and is now auctioning off some of which
she and Jean collected it isn't easy it
was more than a hockey players had they
lived their hockey life in this era
they'd be millionaires but back then the
paychecks weren't the same the money
shall make from the auction will go to
her two grandchildren and two
great-grandchildren but it's for the
kids
among the items a game-worn Jersey from
1963 the ring Beliveau was wearing when
he signed his first contract and two
items from the night he scored his 500th
goal the puck he put in the net and the
size 11 skates he had on his feet the
auction is being conducted online there
are three weeks left for bidding one of
the things men ebony vocês the money
might go towards is paying for Joe's
great-grandchildren as they down the
road learn to play hockey my car from
Global News Montreal and that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Robin Gill
tonight your Canada is Princess Louise
Falls in Ontario thank you for watching
have a great night
[Music]